problema 6 sea fx igual al seno de x
elevado al cuadrado más el coste no de x
la gráfica de ye igual al valor absoluto
de la derivada quinta de fx se muestra a
continuación no lo sé poniendo aquí para
ahorrar espacio sin embargo cuando no
ocupemos el inciso de la voy a poner la
gráfica del jeep
resolvamos el inciso dice escribe los
primeros cuatro términos no nulos de la
serie de taylor para el seno de x
alrededor de x0 y escribe los primeros
cuatro términos no nulos de la serie de
taylor para el seno de x elevado al
cuadrado alrededor también del 0 pues
empecemos vamos a recordar que era la
aproximación por series de taylor
entonces esto es muy plano cartesiano y
supongamos que yo tengo una función
cualquiera ahora bien él aproximarme al
punto x igual a cero por una serie de
taylor by es de un punto x igual a cero
va a depender de los términos que tenga
si yo tengo un término de miseria de
taylor va a aparecer una recta constante
si yo tengo dos términos va a aparecer
una recta muy parecida a ésta si yo
tuviera tres términos entonces va a ser
una parábola muy parecida a esta
aproximando en el punto x igual a cero y
yo tuviera cuatro términos que sería una
función kubica entonces esto es lo que
yo voy a querer hacer para aproximar una
serie de taylor esta vez alrededor del
seno de x entonces vamos a recordar lo
que era matemáticamente
x es aproximadamente por su serie de
taylor igual a quien a bueno primero
teníamos que agarrar un punto de
referencia en este caso es el 0 y es la
función evaluada en 0 más la primera
derivada evaluada en 0 de la función x x
más la segunda derivada de la función
evaluado en 0 por x cuadrado entre 2
factorial más picas que según un patrón
aquí es la primera derivada la segunda
derivada por ex cuadrada entre el factor
ya la que va a ser la tercera derivada
evaluada en 0 por x cúbica entre tres
factorial y la siguiente va a ser la
cuarta derivada evaluada en 0 x x 4
entre 4 factorial y así sucesivamente es
muy importante mencionar que entre más
términos tengamos nuestra aproximación
va a ser mejor de hecho si tuviéramos
una infinidad de términos nuestra
aproximación sería la función misma pero
bueno la primera parte del inciso dice
escribe los primeros cuatro términos de
la serie de taylor para el seno de x
alrededor de x igual a cero esto ya lo
había hecho cuando yo intentaba
es la identidad de oier pero vamos a
hacerlo de nuevo
gx voy a ponerlo con un color distinto
para romper la monotonía va a ser igual
al seno de x yo lo que quiero es una
aproximación por serie
entonces vamos a calcular quien es g de
0 pues es 0900 y quién es la primera
derivada del seno pues la primera
derivada del seno es el coseno de x y si
lo evaluamos la primera derivada en 0
pues va a ser coseno de 0 que es uno muy
bien calculemos la segunda derivada
heavy prima de x es igual a la derivada
del coseno que es el menos seno de x y
que mi prima evaluada en 0 pues es el
seno de 00 por menos pues también es 0
bien sigamos la tercera derivada quién
va a ser a pues la derivada de menos
x que es menos coseno de x el signo se
mantiene y la derivada del 0 es el
coseno de x y si evaluamos la tercera
derivada en 0 me va a dar menos 1 porque
el coste no de cero es 1 y creo que
ustedes ya encontraron el patrón de
todas maneras le voy a seguir pero creo
que ya está fácil encontrar el patrón la
cuarta derivada de x quién va a ser pues
la derivada del coche
no sé no por menos me va a dar el seno
otra vez de equis y si lo evaluamos en
cero pues otra vez nos va a dar cero
entonces está que de cero es lo mismo
que cuarta evaluado en cero se están
empezando a repetir las derivadas y la
evaluación en cero entonces esto es lo
mismo que el cuarta de cero y si
nosotros le seguimos pues va a ser la
derivada del seno que es el consejero
entonces si se dan cuenta es unas
derivadas cíclicas por lo tanto que
quinta en cero va a ser 1 y que se está
en 0 pues va a ser cero otra vez y así
sucesivamente que es extender o es cero
ig
séptima en evaluada en 0 va a ser menos
uno que séptima evaluada en cero es
igual a menos uno y así sucesivamente
entonces al menos ya encontramos el
patrón y creo que ya con esto podemos
resolver la primera parte del inciso
queremos los primeros cuatro términos de
mi serie de taylor para el seno de x
alrededor del cero entonces vamos a
intentar hacerlo seno de x es
aproximadamente primero me pide f en
cero pero en cero es cero entonces no es
necesario ponerlo este término se va
después
efe prima evaluada en cero por equis
pero que prima evaluar en ceros uno por
equis pues me va a dar x entonces f
prima evaluada en 0 por x me da x a esto
hay que sumarle la segunda derivada
evaluada en 0 pero 0 entonces aquí ya no
es necesario poner nada más después hay
que sumarle a la tercera derivada
evaluada en cero por equis kubica entre
tres factores que es 1 no esperen a que
algo mal este signo de igual para este
signo de igual o menos aquí me confunde
con seno de cero es uno por menos es
menos 1 entonces ya así queda
más claro que esto es menos 1 y menos 1
por equis púbica entre 3 factorial me da
menos x cúbica entre 3 factoriales menos
equis kubica entre 3 factoriales ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa con la cuarta
derivada de valuada en 0 por la cuarta
derivada evaluada en cero es cero otra
vez entonces se va y la quinta pues va a
ser 1 por x quinta entre 5 factorial
aquí tenemos el término de la quinta
derivada evaluada en 0 más pues la sexta
se va porque es 0 más la séptima
derivada evaluada en 0 que es menos 1
entonces no va a quedar menos 1 por x
séptima entre 7 factorial y que creen ya
tenemos aquí los primeros cuatro
términos de mi serie de taylor que no
son nulos que no se hacen cero
entonces ya los tenemos aquí y por lo
tanto ya tenemos la primera parte del
inciso a y es un momento perfecto de
empezar a ver la segunda parte del
inciso a que dice escribe los primeros
cuatro términos no nulos de la serie de
taylor para el seno de x elevado al
cuadrado alrededor de 0 y pues bueno lo
primero que uno pensaría es nueva
las derivadas de seno de x al cuadrado
la primera segunda tercera derivada sin
embargo se ve un poco complicado y algo
engorroso entonces ya calculamos la
aproximación en series de taylor del
seno de x pues por lo tanto si nosotros
sustituimos x x x cuadrada ya tenemos
aproximación en series de taylor y no
tenemos que complicarnos más la vida me
va a quedar x cuadrada menos equis
cuadrada elevada al cubo entre 3
factorial más x elevado al cuadrado ha
elevado a la quinta entre 5 factorial
darse cuenta que lo único que estamos
haciendo es poner en lugar de x x
cuadrada menos equis cuadrada elevada a
la séptima entre 7 factorial
y ya está con esto encontramos los
primeros cuatro términos que no son
nulos de la serie de taylor que aproxima
al seno de x elevado al cuadrado
alrededor del cero y desde cuenta de la
importancia de utilizar la aproximación
para el seno de x en lugar de no
meternos en problemas con las derivadas
del seno de x elevado al cuadrado
utilizamos la aproximación que ya
habíamos sacado para el seno de x si
sirve para x pues sirve para x cuadrada
y bueno si simplificamos me queda x
- x sexta entre 3 factorial + x décima
entre 5 factorial menos x a la 14 entre
7 factorial y ya con esto resolvemos la
segunda parte del inciso a de este
problema 6